as we look back some more local items me
dude
I'm Chris and today I want to talk to
you about three ways three ways you can
improve your design as we look back on
some of our logo critiques we kept
noticing consistent issues popping up
right I'm gonna play some clips after
the clips will do a quick breakdown and
talk about how you can avoid these three
common mistakes and hopefully improve
your design so here's this logo this
one's coming from Bao we ding win it's
using I believe for taurah its trident
and he's got two bars on the top and the
bottom now this feels really nice to me
here's what I like about this there's a
graphic element so it feels like a
symbol but I can read it and it's well
integrated what I don't like about it is
where the bars on the top and the bottom
of the tried land the way that you say
it is tri dent so I wanted to emphasize
one syllable or the other so we don't
want to use graphic elements purely for
decoration we want to reinforce and make
the logo even more legible the next up
is hoodlum done by Ashlyn Harris logo
created for hoodlum a clothing line for
the people who don't fit in with the
rest
I like this lock up you're trying to get
everything nice and tight and that's a
good thing although I don't necessarily
love the modifications that you made I
don't like how the Lu come together
because the way that these ten serif
typefaces terminate is with a straight
line right so when you first of all put
an angle and you kind of follow the
curvature that you it just makes it look
like that letter form is from some other
typeface the other thing is you've kind
of cut off the H basically the bottom of
the H and put a bar across I like that
as a visual element but you're also
making the H very hard to read somebody
might look at that and see as a symbol
like some kind of abstract crown or
something and then read it as odd l'm so
legibility should supersede any kind of
decorative element that you do next up
is from Roberto Ramos the name of my
brand is avi the three eyes is the
three-point line half-court line and the
other three-point line okay first of all
I like this mark it does feel a little
bit like retro 80s logo
cool except for I thought it read audio
AUD IO and then when I read it was for
avi I was thinking this isn't read as
obvious at all no I thought it was audio
as well right it would be a pretty good
mark for audio okay so Roberto good mark
and you guys please please please make
sure it reads reading the your word mark
on your logo is very important it
supersedes all the other decisions that
you're making all right this is from Jay
Goosen it's a book and it's a warm it
works so here's where maybe the type
pairing with the mark feels a little bit
off a lot of you guys are really good at
drawing symbols I think you just need to
learn how to pair it with a different
typeface and the lock-up is important
here's where I'm thinking you can play
around mixing two weights or you look in
the lighter weight and then warm is in
the bolder typeface break it up next up
Jacob Keeling my take on a driverless
car logo Oh interesting it's an
exploration of the GPS symbol whoo it
does feel like automotive it's got that
nice kind of Chevron crest shape paired
with a nice bold sans-serif typeface it
has this point which is that reads like
the letter A so autónoma it makes sense
to me and it's also a navigation system
so that's the pointer pointing north
those are two good things and it's not
illustrating like we talked about this
before you don't want to illustrate what
it does you want to show a guy like
giving you directions it's it's abstract
but it's clear what it is reminds me of
Tesla a little bit actually it reminds
me of Star Trek everybody gonna be
reminded of something here so the
natural thing is to compare always and
designers are like famous for comparing
this is both good and bad I like to look
at things for what they are because I
always feel like everything's already
been done and as long as there's not a
navigation system that looks just like
this I'm good with that because you know
you can't own a triangle you can't own a
square or trapezoid this is for
everybody to use sure I wasn't saying
was a bad no everything you say I'm
reacting to like how people are it's
just like that and then people dismiss
it uh-huh
and then they make something really ugly
yeah okay so let me share with you the
mistakes I saw on how to fix them
always
in black-and-white no colors no textures
this will make it easier for you to
focus on the important aspects of the
logo things like hierarchy contrast and
legibility legibility legibility
legibility not being able to read the
logo pretty serious mistake as you
design your logo you are making lots of
little decisions chopping letters
changing fonts etc it's easy to get a
carried away to the point in which the
mark becomes really difficult to read
the solution always ask yourself is it
legible does it read well legibility
should supersede every other
consideration if you remember this you
will make the mistake of making your
logo hard to read critiquing isn't art
it's not that anybody can just throw out
a random comment and think that
somebody's gonna derive useful
information so when somebody asks you
for your opinion just take a moment to
think to process and look at something
and try not to react right off the bat I
like to think of it like peeling an
onion
let me explain one I start by simply
describing what I'm seeing just what's
clearly there the typeface the shapes
the curves the points the line weights
etc no judgments then I start to notice
how certain things make me feel and I
describe them using phrases like this
feels funny to me or I like this finally
having peeled back all the layers
I feel the context has been set and I
can start sharing ideas for things that
we can do to improve okay there you have
it three common mistakes designers make
on how you can avoid them I hope you
enjoyed this video and you feel like
you're a better designer than you were
five minutes ago want to submit your
logo for a critique it's pretty
straightforward make sure you follow us
on Facebook that the future is here the
future is spelt with no e but you should
know that by now
all right make sure you guys like
comment subscribe and hit that Bell
goodbye and see you next time
[Music]